hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll it's
kind of a cliche to say that even though
in some sense our lives change quite
rapidly because of the advance of
Technology often it doesn't seem like
it's changing that rapidly like we
anticipate certain things like where's
my jet pack and rocket car and whatever
and we're not seeing those things so we
miss the changes that are actually
happening the most obvious example here
is the computer right when I was growing
up we did not have computers in my house
uh when I was in high school there was a
computer lab you could go to when I was
in college you could go to the
department and work on the computers
there but I didn't have my own that
wasn't until grad school that I really
late in grad school that I really
started uh that I bought my first
personal computer and the Very idea of a
computer and what it is should not be
taken for granted even though that's
what we do you know a computer is not
just a calculator computers do lots of
things the miracle of the computers we
use now is that they are general purpose
machines you can use a computer to watch
movies listen to podcasts read your
email play games calculate important
integrals if that's the kind of thing
you'd like to do and it kind of goes
back to Alan Turing the one who really
first argued for the generalness of
computers it turns out that this feature
of computers their generalness their
flexibility is closely related to their
vulnerabilities we all know that there
are worries that we have about computer
hacking Bringing Down the internet
stealing our emails things like that
today's guest is Scott Shapiro and he's
going to tell us a little bit about the
philosophy and Technology of computer
hacking it's somewhat reminiscent of our
recent conversation with Nita farahani
who is a law professor and philosophy
Professor who talked about the privacy
issues that come up when you have the
possibility of reading your mind with
technology neuroscanning and part of the
lesson there the worry was that human
beings when faced with a trade-off
between privacy and convenience are
almost always going to choose
convenience we really like convenience
we will give away our privacy today with
Scott we're going to talk about computer
hacking and the danger that that has for
us and part of the lesson is that when
faced with security versus convenience
human beings often choose convenience
but it actually is going to go deeper
than that even people who are pretty
well-meaning and try their best to
choose security uh human beings they're
always the problem they get in the way
that's where it becomes a philosophical
issue as well as a tech issue and a
legal issue how do we think about the
way to shape human beings and their
relationships with the machines they use
in such a way to make us a little bit
more secure Scott Shapiro has a new book
out called Fancy bear goes fishing
that's fishing with a p-h-i-s-h and the
subtitle is the dark history of the
information age in five extraordinary
hacks it's a detailed very readable and
fun to read but there's a lot of stuff
in there but the five hacks that he
chooses historically you know these five
examples of when people hacked into the
computers in one way or the other
they're very fun you learn a lot about
who becomes a hacker why they do it and
what the rest of us who are hopefully
not hackers Canon should do to stop it
from happening to us so that's useful
advice I think for all of us let's go
[Music]
thank you
Scott Shapiro welcome to the mindscape
podcast oh thank you so much Sean for
having me I think this is one of those
episodes where a little bit of history
is going to help us a little bit of path
dependence as to how we got here because
you're a philosophy Professor I know
also in the law school so that's a
that's kind of a natural uh intersection
but now we're talking about hacking and
cyber security which is maybe not so
natural how did we get here and what did
these things have to do with each other
yeah sure so I I got so two things so
first of all I have
um a computer science background like so
many
um young boys people my uh my age I grew
up in the 1970s and 80s when the
personal computer Revolution came along
and my class room in ninth grade had a
TRS-80 from Radio Shack and my parents
bought me an Apple too and you know for
the first time in the history of the
world you could go into a store and buy
a general uh all-purpose computer
um and you know I mean for so many
people
um I was Intoxicated by it and um you
know coding all the time and then when I
I I
um uh studied computer science at
Columbia and
um I had a computer company and um uh
before the in before before the World
Wide Web came okay
um came on and so I was just I I was a
computer person until I switched to be a
law and philosophy person so that's the
first thing but really
um the the way I got into this was that
my previous work had been on the history
of war that is the in a book I had
published before the the fancy bear
called the internationalist it was a
story about
how War had gone from being a perfectly
legitimate way in which states enforced
their rights to Illegal
um that war is
um is illegal except in cases of
self-defense and then people so it was
like from 1600 to
2015 that was like the history and then
of course people said well what about
2016 what about 2017 what about cyber
war and I was like oh what about cyber
War that's super interesting and uh that
sucked me into this space
um and uh it was it was it it it was
incredibly interesting journey I mean
it's incredibly interesting field of
cyber security are you teaching
philosophy courses that relate to this
topic
um so it's funny because when I first
started teaching I taught this course
with two other colleagues one a law
professor on a Hathaway and another one
a mathematical cryptographer
um Joan feigenbaum and we Toyota class
called the law and Technology of cyber
conflict where half the students were
computer scientists half the students
were law students and so we'd Explain
the law to the technology people and the
technology to the law people and it was
just terrible just like the absolute
worst course I ever taught in my life
and that is because
um you know both law and
computer science their technical
subjects and so at any given time half
the class was bored and the other half
was confused and
um we just switched back and forth
throughout the semester and then I
realized that you know you can't well at
least I hadn't figured out how to teach
all of it together so I so I've taught
just a pure hacking class just pure
technology then a pure law class and
then just a pure philosophy class
um to try to figure out how to get how
to get into the subject and the book in
some sense is a combination of all those
what is the name of the philosophy class
oh it's it was called the philosophy of
Internet hacking okay
I mean one of the main ideas of the book
is that um that hackers don't just
exploit computer code but also the
philosophical principles of computation
and so it says something I'm I I hope
we'll talk about but uh to me the
technical philosophical and legal are
really tightly connected yeah okay and I
could not be too um professorial here
but let us Define the term hacking what
do we mean exactly because this might
not even mean the thing that people
think it means yeah so I I when I use
the term hacking I use it as an activity
that attempts to defeat a security
control so there are all these controls
that are put on our computers like have
to enter credentials username and
passwords that's a security control and
if you can defeat that security control
you have hacked that system and so so
like if you just leave your computer
open
um and somebody comes over and reads
your email they have not hacked your
computer because they have not defeated
anything that was designed for you not
to do it unless they picked your lock
um into your into your into your room or
something like that but if they trick
you into sending them your email address
or your password I should say
right so that so that that's exactly
right so if they if they somehow
um use fraud deception in order to work
around something that was designed for
you not to get gain access to the
account that is hacking but I think a
lot of people probably have in mind the
idea of uh viruses or some kind of tools
that let you get around a firewall so is
that still a lot I mean getting people
sending you their passwords is great but
is there still a lot of uh trixiness
with viruses and worms and so forth and
do we need to know the difference
between a virus and a worm yeah right
exactly so you know I'm a philosopher so
whereas you know other people may not be
that obsessed with what is the
difference between a virus and a worm I
was particularly obsessed with like
trying to come up with you know why
they're different and I I can talk about
it but one of the things I try to show
is that viruses and worms which very big
basically one might consider to be
self-replicating computer programs
they all use forms of trickery but they
use trickery in different ways viruses
use trickery to get users to execute
them to click on links to download them
worms trick not users but their
operating systems or their other other
types of network protocols or or like so
there's always trickery going on the
question is who's being tricked I guess
I'm not sure how that relates to what I
had in mind maybe I'm taking the
biological metaphor too seriously but I
think of viruses as things that live
within another program and worms that
things that are living organisms by
themselves yeah no that so in in some
sense
um that was the historical origin of the
terms virus and worm so if for example
worms from tapeworms and tapeworms or
hermaphroditic
organisms that can reproduce by
themselves and so that was the idea of a
worm the biological metaphor helps but
as I try to show in the book it doesn't
actually really work
there are fully self-contained viruses
there are worms that are part of other
computer programs so
um it the the difference between virus
and worms is not whether they're
Standalone or part of something else
they really two main differences one is
um who who executes them is it is it the
user does that does the user need to
click right on the thing and
um uh whereas a worm can can as
autonomous can operate by itself and the
second is like how does it spread does
it spread through networks worms spread
through networks and that's why worms
are so dangerous on the internet Because
the Internet wins a network of networks
and viruses are are local that as they
infect your computer but they don't move
from one computer to another via
Networks okay how do they move from one
computer well you know they used to
um the main way in which viruses used to
travel what was called sneakernet just
like you just get a get a you'd have a
flop you you'd have a game that had a
virus in it you put your floppy in there
and you give it to your friend and they
would put the floppy into their hard
drive into their into their floppy drive
and then they would get the virus
um that that's the way it normally
happened it the in the early 1990s
um it was estimated that it took two
weeks for a virus to get from Europe to
the United States that's I'm gladly uh
went over that because you and I are
indeed part of that generation that use
floppy drives during our formative years
but I bet a lot of people listening uh
have no idea what we're talking about
here the floppy disks are known only as
a joke right like they knew that that's
an ancient technology energy no
absolutely and so I mean so there's the
floppy disk so there's the eight and a
half floppy they were really floppy if
you held them by the corner they really
did flop over then you had the five and
a quarter which was less floppy but
still pretty floppy and then you had the
hard the hard floppy discs the three and
a half inch ones
um and that's what you know yeah I try
to tell my students this because they're
also upsettingly young
um but like when you save your Your Word
document you're clicking on a floppy
Drive icon that they've maybe they
haven't seen or haven't remembered the
iconography will live forever and then
before getting into the so sorry let's
back up you've written a book uh fancy
bear goes fishing and it you will talk
about you talk in the book about these
you pick out five
paradigmatic I suppose hacks that that
we'll get through because they're all
really great stories and they illustrate
some of the points
um but before we go into the details
about I do want to get some of the
philosophical background on the table
you you talk about how
the idea of just stopping hacking is a
little bit utopian it's not going to
happen it's sort of in the notion of a
computer that it can be hacked could you
is that is that an accurate paraphrase
yes exactly it's not like people are
silly or they make mistakes it is part
of the ultimate fabric of the universe
you cannot make computers that are
unhackable and this goes back to Alan
Turing who gets name checked a lot yes
it does go back to Alan Turing what I
think is so
um fascinating about touring of I mean
Turing is one of one of the most
fascinating figures in the history of
science
um certainly of the 20th century and you
know when you know some of the listeners
might have heard of things like Turing
machines that are named after Alan
Turing Alan Turing in 1936 he's 20. he
he wrote it when he was 23 publishing
he's 24 comes up with this Theory
of how compute general computing devices
are possible like you can make a
mechanical
general computing device and and this is
just this is of course
um a massive intellectual breakthrough
and and the principles that he lay lays
out for how general computing devices
are possible
um which we can go into
turns out to be exactly the principles
that hackers exploit
when they hack a computer so and I'm
happy to talk about this because I think
this is one of the message main messages
of the book is that the very things that
make computers possible make hacking
possible and you can't get rid of one
without the other and that's like a such
a deep yeah a part of the world of the
the metaphysics so to speak of the world
that no amount of money time or effort
is ever going to change that on
occasional rare moments I begin to think
that I'm a little bit smart and then I
remember people like Alan Turing who
when they're 23 years old invent the
general theory of a Computing machine oh
it's just crazy it not only see not only
does he come up with this idea that
General computers uh uh general
computing devices are possible he he
does that to show that computers can
solve every problem right
um which you know talk about you know
like that is um that is Galaxy brain
stuff like you can like okay computers
possible actually general computing you
can solve any solvable problem but you
know what there are problems that not no
no finite devices ever going to solve
like in one article I still struggle
with that fact that he got 100 years ago
yeah yeah it's just it's just
astonishing to talk about you know going
from first principles and just and just
driving just through pure reason to
figure out something unbelievably deep
about about the universe is just it's
mind-boggling and like you makes me feel
bad about myself yeah I think so I think
it's okay but if I'm if I'm gonna like
package the the connection there and you
can fill in the details it's because
touring appreciated that there's not
quite as sharp a distinction between
data and code as you might have expected
yeah so I mean this this turns out to be
I I think of this as like
um you know one of the two or three
greatest
philosophical discoveries of the 20th
century that no one knows about or I
shouldn't say no one knows about I mean
lots of people know about it of course
but they don't appreciate it um it as a
just an um massive
um intellectual breakthrough so the idea
is that you know we we have these two
categories of things code and data so
code
instructions active does things data
information passive has things done to
it and so you know so shut the door
print your resume add two numbers that's
code
um two that's data it's 80 degrees
outside
um and so you might think like these
things are so different
from one another one does something
other thing the other thing has
something done to it
um once acted once passed me so you
might think like they're so different
they can't possibly be represented by
the same symbols I mean we normally
think of code AS represented by you know
at least for programmers we think of it
as like English or english-like words
natural language data we think is
normally represented by numbers although
it doesn't have to be so these seems to
be so like numbers and words seem to be
so different and what what what
um Turing did building on the inside of
of
um Kurt girdle the great uh logician
which is that you can always take code
and turn it into a number
um and a unique number
um and so you could have code and data
represented by numbers by the same
symbols and since all numbers can be
represented by binary symbols ones and
zeros you could have code and data these
very different things represented by the
same strings of ones and zeros which
means that your computer need only
understand one language the language of
ones and zeros and it it means that you
don't have to rebuild your computer
every time you want to run a different
program which is what you know team of
women programmers you had to do in the
1940s with the eniac they they didn't
have software everything was Hardware
she had to change everything if you use
the Turing process of converting code
into numbers what you could do is have a
computer that accepts numbers and then
runs it as code except numbers treated
as data and then run the code on the
data which makes
that's why I only have one laptop as as
opposed to
87 for every application that I use
because I can just always download or
load
code into my computer
part of me this is very unfair but part
of me thinking like a physicist wants to
say of course code and data are the same
because they're all atoms and they're
thinking about them as either coder data
is a human choice that we make for our
convenience and and touring is really
just reminding us that there's a
commonality there that this human
invention is not absolute
yeah so but you know right now you're I
mean that's that's absolutely true but
you know I just want to notice that uh
point out that you're you're I mean
quite naturally because in some sense
this was another great Advance
um of tourings which is that you're
trying to
assimilate a computer Computing device
to a physical system
um and that was another great discovery
actually of Turing that computation is a
physical process and that you could
build a Contraption a mechanical
contraption that just manipulates
symbols according to the laws of physics
and somehow through
um some very basic manipulation
um uh actions like you know writing the
number one erasing the number one moving
along a tape that was sufficient for
solving every solvable problem so when
you say yes of course
you know words or atoms or um you know
actually the the the
um the the string is is made up of atoms
well that is to that is to use the other
Insight of Turing which is that computer
device uh Computing devices are physical
devices
and and these insights together are what
underlie the claim that hacking is
always going to be with us
yeah yeah so let me just take the first
the second thing that I just mentioned
about you know Computing devices are
physical devices for manipulating
symbols you know that is one of the main
ways in which hacking occurs which is
that hackers exploit the physical
limitations of physical systems
um you know think of it think of
polygraphs
so a polygraph is a way of trying to
Let's assume that they're good you know
that they work okay for for the moment
okay um the idea of a polygraph is to
try to peer into your mind
um not by asking and not by actually
reading the neural patterns in your head
but to try to see that your brain is
connected to your body and that we might
be able to discover through increased
heart rate or sweating that you think
something
um and and that's a way of hacking
um uh the the physical body human body
to figure out what's going on
um in um cyber security this is called a
side Channel attack it's to try to read
off information from the changes in the
physical system that's being studied so
you know there are all these cool things
where or you know hackers can discover
your passcode because you have an
accelerometer in your in your smartphone
which can tell which numbers you've uh
um because the the the
um the phone shifts a little bit um and
so they're they're very sophisticated
um
um exploits that use this the second one
is
um in the book I call this Duality which
is the first principle we had been
talking about that code and data are can
be represented by the same symbols well
if they can be represented by the same
symbols when the computer or the user is
expecting data the hacker can send code
um and that is the other major way in
which hacking occurs so one thing I
think you can see is that the very thing
that makes computers possible that is
that they're physical devices and that
they can manipulate both code and data
through binary symbols are the very
things that get exploited by hackers and
when I I mean
it
thinking about it this way I think kind
of takes things that seem very
disconnected from one another and they
show the common things uh commonalities
so phishing attempts
um are attempts to exploit imperfect
human psychology
um that's be we have imperfect human
psychology because we need shortcuts
um the same thing with side Channel
attacks on computers they're they're
also exploiting the physical nature of
the system so
that's a way of seeing how how to group
hacks together and and there's one other
distinction that you raised that I
really liked between up code and down
code while we're talking about code so
uh what is that yeah sure so
um so so you know think think when
you're typing on your computer
um down code is all the code below your
fingertips so your operating system your
application Network protocols how your
router works firmware all that kind of
stuff up code is all the norms and rules
and code above your fingertips so your
psychology social Norms legal Norms
professional ethics terms of service
employment contracts all the Norms that
go above and I call that up code and I
the I the standard way that people think
about cyber security and hacking is is
pure is almost purely through a down
code lens so they think okay we got some
technical vulnerability we got some bug
let's fix it and the argument that I
make in the book is that this is a bad
way to address cyber security that we
ought to be looking at the up code the
Norms which provide incentives for
um for coders and for users to use their
computers in a certain way to develop
code in a certain way and so what we
ought to be looking for is not so much
the technical vulnerabilities and the
down code but the human and political
and social vulnerabilities in the up
code and let's look at exactly those so
you have these wonderful examples and I
like the very first one uh Robert Morris
in in
1988 because I remember I was a first
year grad student at that time at
Harvard and the first this is big news
the internet went down the internet was
a very tiny thing at the time but uh
there it's it shows one of these human
psychological aspects because I was at
Harvard the first guess was that this is
somehow affiliated with MIT but then at
some point there was a a idea that in
fact fact the person who did it was
affiliated with Harvard and they were
very proud they were happy like that we
beat MIT somehow it turned out not to
exactly be the full story in either way
but tell us what the story was yeah sure
did you know Cliff Stoll
um I I've seen him give talks and I read
his cuckoo eggs okay because he was uh
he's an astronomer uh uh
um and a computer security expert who
was at Harvard at the time and who also
spent
um a a central role in trying to
remediate and explain what had happened
um so here's what happened
um right it's a 1988 November 2nd
um 1988 the Robert Morris Jr who's a
first year graduate student in computer
science at Cornell University had been a
Harvard undergraduate
um logs into Richard stallman's
um uh email a computer account
in at MIT because Richard stallman man
who is the often known as the father of
free and open source software
um he didn't have a password on his
account
um and um you know so so Robert Morris
did not hack the MIT
computer but what he did was he released
three binary files which
um he released as an experiment the
basic idea of the of the Swarm that he
created was it exploited some uh
multiple vulnerabilities in the Unix
operating systems particularly
um uh Unix
um 4.2 the Berkeley software
distribution 4.2 which was the first
opera first Unix distribution uh or I
should say first major Unix distribution
that was hooked up to the Internet
um and so what Robert Morris did was he
exploited those vulnerabilities because
he was kind of a he was uh he was
extraordinarily knowledgeable and he was
really just interested in figuring out
like how big the internet was you know
it was a science experiment for him and
for reasons which I can go into
um the worm was so effective at
infecting computers that it reinfected
those computers over and over again and
so these computers crashed not because
he was trying to crash them but because
they were so busy copying worms and
distributing them the it's a it you know
one of the things that so on the same
age as Robert Morris Jr he is right now
A tenured professor at MIT his best his
friend that I talk about in the book
Paul Graham Paul Graham is the one of
the founders of uh y combinator
um giant uh
um Tech Venture Capital
firm that you know is responsible for
funding Dropbox and Airbnb and stuff
like that but this is a story of like
when they're grad students
um and um you know when the whole when
the internet goes down it's on the cover
of the New York Times on the you know on
the national on national news Robert
Morris Jr has to call Robert Moore
Senior Bob Morris who's his dad who's
the head of cyber security for the NSA
um just imagine you know crash crashing
the internet and you have to tell your
dad who's responsible for
um uh cyber security for the National
Security uh agency I mean just an
incredible
um uh like just it makes it just makes
me cringe every time I I think about it
and then he he gets um prosecuted and
convicted for the first one to be
convicted of violating the computer
fraud or an Abuse Act
um and he does not go to jail but um
it's uh it's a very it's harrowing story
of what he went through and just so
people are correctly normalizing their
expectations here the internet existed
in 1988 but it was a different thing
what we call the World Wide Web did not
exist that's right so one of the things
I try to explain in the book right is
that you know the web and the internet
are often conflated for you know for for
good reasons
um in part because the web is a protocol
for that they that works on top of the
internet
um and so like just like email uses the
internet browsers use the internet
um and um it the the the the the World
Wide Web is
created I think a year later in 1989 and
then it comes online with the first
browser in the 1993 with Mosaic which
becomes Netscape so we're talking like
right before
um everyone starts thinking about the
web and the internet and one of the
things that's fascinating I didn't
realize this from my um from my research
the first time Americans or anybody had
ever heard the word internet before
um I was kind of shocked about this and
they don't even know how to like when
when when newspapers are writing this up
they don't even know how to how to refer
to it they said the internet is it
internet is it the internet network is
it the internet with the N uh second n
capitalized a lot of experimenting but
the first time people know that the
internet exists it basically is when it
crashes and it was
essentially it wasn't malicious right it
was like you said it was kind of a
science experiment it was not an attempt
to bring down the internet it was kind
of like yeah we're young and it's a
Brave New World let's see what we can do
yeah I mean so you know I I the the
thing is that um I think it was so
shocking to people precisely because it
wasn't malicious
um it was like you know Reverend Morse
Jr had found security vulnerabilities in
Internet protocols
um before
um he was ex he was like basically the
network administrator for Harvard before
he went to Cornell I mean he was a you
know he was
you know a white hat you know he's one
of the good guys
um and one of one of our one of our
people
um crashed the internet what would a
black hat do right
um and that that that that I think that
just freaked everyone out scared
everyone of course everyone was worried
about
um connect as it was the Internet
connected to uh the nuclear Arsenal
um the the movie War games
um which maybe you know
um some of your listeners remember I bet
you remember it Matthew Broderick film
which um tells the story of how this
teenager uh kind of uh what's now equal
it War dialing after War Games is it
randomly dialing numbers through his
modem and then connects to a NORAD
computer which he thinks is a video game
uh repository and he almost starts World
War 3 and this means amazing that Ronald
Reagan sees this movie at the White
House and then freaks out and then gets
everyone to like get like can this
really happen and we get the next year
the computer for the first um iteration
the computer for an Abuse Act the first
federal law against hacking
um you know it's it it's too perfect you
know movie star president sees this
movie we get this law and then a couple
of years later you the whole internet
goes down and people you know see these
things connected and they get very very
very
um uh anxious and that anxiety in many
ways has not gone away
I'm always fascinated by the
similarities but also differences
between a complex system like the
internet or even a single computer and
complex systems like a living organism
or an ecosystem which the biggest single
difference is that one was designed at
least partly and the other one kind of
evolved uh does that difference make the
internet more or less vulnerable you
know it sort of hasn't grown up through
being buffeted by a whole bunch of
different evolutionary challenges but on
the other hand there's people trying to
keep it safe uh is there an easy
question to answer
um no it's really I mean you know like
any question involving complex systems
is not easy to answer
um and so um and that's not even I I
would be honest it's not even my area
um I will say
um that
two things of of real importance
um comparing computers to biological
systems so the first one is that the
person who was most moved by the analogy
was the you know when another
um Genius of the 20th century John Von
Neumann and John Von Neumann uh was he
was
involved
um uh in the eniac which is first
electronic computer
um and then he built he's very
um Central to building the first digital
computer the edvac which uses the system
that we talked about earlier of loading
code into your computer and then loading
data so you don't have to rebuild it
every time and so one of the things that
Von Neumann discovered
when he um was trying to build this
computer was how ridiculously vulnerable
they are like one little one little
vacuum tube and it's gone
um and he's like but human beings or
like uh you know moths or fruit flies
it's not like that at all yeah you know
things get messed up all the time and
yet and yet
um biological systems are so resilient
so he he set out to figure out how could
it be that that biological systems is so
resilient but computers are the
computers that he has seen were so
fragile and he came up with the idea
that what we need to understand that
what what biological systems do is that
they're so resilient because they're
self-replicating that they're parts that
can rebuild their parts
um and this idea of like Von Neumann has
how can how is self-replication possible
um becomes the basis for how computer
viruses and computer worms are possible
so the very things that make life
possible also are the things that make
computer viruses possible and that's a
really fascinating
um uh this is again another one of these
ideas which is that you can't have the
good without the bad you can't have
computers without hacking you can't have
life without the possibility of cancer
or you know malware
of sorts so the the connection between
biological systems and computer systems
has been incredibly important historical
and intellectual uh analogy have has any
progress been made at getting computer
systems either Hardware or software to
be more self-repairing than they would
be it doesn't seem that way from my
novice point of view yeah no so they're
the you know there are lots and lots of
mathematical models out there for
self-repairing automata
um uh and
um people have tried to
um uh the the there's now
um
um efforts to
um to create especially using AI
engine's self-repairing code right
um uh and so there have been all these
um attempts
um it will be
fascinating
to see
when automata are sophisticated enough
to take human form and they can
regenerate their own parts that will be
that'll be unbelievable good
all right uh we don't want to get too
hung up Robert Morris was a Pioneer
absolutely but then we take a turn for
the slightly darker with literally Dark
Avenger these people are not you know
the most creative at coming up with uh
names for themselves but Dark Avenger
captures something right yeah no so so
the second story is like the Bulgarian
virus factories in the early 1990s so
for people who remember this stuff
um Bulgarian viruses were like the big
thing in the early 1990s and I was
fascinated by
like why like why Bulgaria that country
right of all of all places why why were
the bulgarians so into virus writing and
why were they so good at it and besides
what are viruses
um and um so it turns out the story so
what I did talk about is like what what
computer viruses are the
self-replicating programs which are user
executed and don't use networks to to
travel
which makes a lot of sense at the time
because in the early 1990s you don't
really have
um personal computers hooked up to
networks it really viruses really do
work
um um travel via sneakernet
um and um the the the so I was really
interested in like what are viruses and
how do they work but
um there was
um this one person named Dark Avenger
who was A Cut Above everyone else in
writing viruses and they
um traveled around the world and it
caused a lot of problems for people and
this person was named Dark Avenger
because he was really
um uh into heavy metal
um and
um and in particular
um uh I believe it was Metallica
um and um no I'm sorry Iron Maiden
excuse me not Metallica okay Iron Man
um and uh he names he he names his
viruses after them he's got strings of
the of the songs in his viruses
um and people don't know who he is now
that by itself is kind of interesting
but Dark Avenger does something which
threatens to
destroy the personal computer industry
which is that he figures out how to
create
a polymorphic virus engine meaning
taking a virus which is down code which
is computer code and introducing
mutations so that every new virus that
gets spread has a new genetic signature
so it's like crispr
um but
um for uh for computer code and the way
in which most antiviral software had had
worked at the time was was called
Signature based it's scanned computer
scanned programs to see does it have the
kind of signature that we can identify
with known uh viral samples and what uh
the mutation engine did was which was
written by Dark Avenger
um is
um uh scrambled it every single time it
was copied which defeated the
um the the antiviral software and
everyone's really really freaked out
because how are they going to solve this
problem
um I will also say it gave me the
opportunity to talk about up code like
why Bulgaria Bulgaria because
at the time in the 1970s and
particularly 1980s Bulgaria was the
Silicon Valley of the Eastern Bloc and
what you did was you had all these
basically young men who were were
underemployed they had excellent
engineering educations they you know
they were very good coders but they had
no outlet they had no job to go to and
so they sat around doing fun stuff
making viruses that you know so this
becomes a kind of a main theme in the
book which is that so much of cyber
crime
is a response to underemployment in in
less developed Tech economies do we know
today who Dark Avenger is slash was
so
um uh we I do I do not
um uh so I don't I do not um uh the
person who did the most work
understanding the mind of virus writers
and
um and um try to uh and and got very
close to Dark Avenger she knows she will
not tell me because she believes she
owes this person anonymity because as a
research subject
um I will I I
after the podcast is over I will tell
you some Communications I've gotten
um um but um I don't know who it is but
I do speculate there's a bunch of
speculation in the book about
who who
he or they are
and this is Sarah Gordon the researcher
who uh yes exactly you know who she is
right yeah so Sarah Gordon is
um she gets a virus she buys a used
computer and she gets of this ping pong
virus and she's like what's a virus and
she gets she goes on the internet and
there's no like web yet so she goes to
single phytonet which is all these viral
bulletin boards hooked up together and
she starts talking to people and she was
a I mean she's a fascinating person
she's uh she did
Crisis counseling for young men and she
kind of got them they were like immature
um slightly stunted young men who hadn't
aged out yet of the process of virus
writing but they probably would
um and she got into she was a Pioneer
she is a Pioneer and she got a lot of
blowback from saying that virus writers
are not evil maniacs
um and I I'm really happy because she
she she was very courageous went out
there made these uh made these claims
and got pilloried by the by the
antivirus community and I'm really happy
that like maybe like 30 years later I've
been able to kind of at least tell her
side of the story how much is this
related to ongoing concerns just about
young men being alienated and uh online
extremism incel communities you know I
mean as a as a world at least in the
western world are we just failing boys
between 15 and 25 and and some of them
become hackers
yes I do think I I do think that that's
right so before there were there were
hackers before incels there were hackers
before people who posted
um Pepe or Elon Musk tweets
um you you you know this you know uh
young young boys and let me just say
something about the gender issue they
are almost all
boys and young men
it is a well unknown phenomenon that um
in the virus in the hacking Community
there are of course women hackers
they're of course excellent excellent
women hackers women have be have um
achieved in very important leadership
positions um in the cyber security cyber
security Community
um but it is still on the the gender
imbalance is quite
um uh bad
um I always joke about like the only
time I at the only time I ever have to
wait to get into that men's room
um uh is at a Hocking conference um you
know women there's no line outside the
women's bathroom so these boys are just
bored they have these skills and I
understand it I I learned and I know how
to hack sometimes I want to do it and
break the law because it's I mean
breaking the law is not fun but but
packing is really fun and you know of
course they wanted to do it
um and one of the suggestions that I
make is and and this is
um been implemented by the UK the
Netherlands United States is catching up
to this which is to try to create
legitimate hacking venues and to try to
divert young offenders into the
legitimate cyber security industry
um as opposed to the
um you know the black hat uh um
activities and you emphasize in the book
that
despite what you might think hacking has
an absolutely crucial social aspect even
if people are Anonymous or pseudonymous
on the Internet they want credit for the
cool things they've done
yes I mean this is the I mean I would
say this was the most shocking social
Insight from my research which was that
hackers are not loners
um the picture that they have is that
they are freaks you know they suffer
from any sort of neurodivergent syndrome
they have multiple personalities
disorders they you know whatever
um but that's just kind of not true
um you know they're like they're like
you and me maybe they're a little kind
of stunted maybe they're little
um you know uh they they have social
anxieties about face-to-face activities
but really they want clout they want
their
their peers online to think that they
are excellent hackers one of the things
that shocked me I I've been uh fortunate
to be able to talk to some of the
hackers that I write about
uh when the hacker one of the hacking
groups uh for the Mariah botnet came to
my class
um my cyber security class and spoke to
my class along with the FBI agent that
caught them and one of the things I was
really fascinated by the the the just
um well maybe we'll talk about it later
but the Mirai botnet
um uh three teenagers who who created
this uh botnet which took down the
internet
um they uh they get caught in part
because they released the code onto the
internet
coders really want to know what other
coders think of their code
um and that is really
amazing
um and
um you know uh people are really
um social you know human beings are
social
um and even hackers are social and if
you really want to
um divert them away from a uh kind of
the dark side you should give them
social incentives to participate like
you know Capture the Flag competitions
mentoring things like that um which is
uh programs which have been created
which I think are really
um uh
um really promising ways of addressing
this problem well let's talk about the
Mirai botnet we don't need to go in the
same order that you went in your book
but it naturally leads in because this
question of motivations is just a
crucial one and as I understand it for
us job was just upset he couldn't get
into a certain class at Rutgers and that
set him down a path
yeah I mean you know it's just like
I mean he he doesn't want to take his
Calculus exam
and so well you know the the first thing
he does is he wants to get into
um an elective class he so he gets in
he's a first year student at Rutgers he
wants to get into a a
and in a higher yeah uh um you know an
upper level elective in advance an upper
level
um computer course I'm a professor I
can't even remember the terms for for
for for for academic courses right so
you must get into an upper upper level
course and as as as we know you know
normally uh for sure students are not
given priority in registration
um more advanced students are so what he
did was is he ddosed the registration uh
website so no one was able to do it and
then when
um when uh when the thing comes back on
he then signs up for it and then he uses
he ddoses the the basically the the the
the the main Rutger system because he
doesn't want to take his Calculus exam
and then he keeps on doing this he he
really does not like the fact that
Rutgers in order to mitigate the uh I
should just Define a DDOS as a
distributed denial service attack it's
an attempt to take
computer website Network offline by
overloading it and consuming its
resources
um he
um he's really upset that the firm that
Rutgers hires encapsula
um to mitigate these DDOS attacks
doesn't use his firm because for us had
this firm called protraf where he did
DDOS mitigation so it's like a classic
um offer you can't refuse he says you
know basically send records you know use
my
my mitigation uh company because your
medication company is terrible because I
can break it and which he did he just
kept on bringing and cost um the Rutgers
had to increase their tuition by several
percent in order to pay for uh all the
cyber security stuff so you know fun and
games but actually caught it it spread
cost uh to the entire student body and
even those fun and games they're legally
it's just good old-fashioned
racketeering he was a Shakedown yeah
it's a it's a classic offer you can't
refuse
um it's racketeering
um and it's it is a very standard story
in the history of cyber security that
the ones who purvey the cures are often
the ones who are also purveying the
diseases
um it's really amazing so you offer
protection services for problems that
you yourself create there's a very kind
of standard mob
um technique and that's what that's what
happens a lot when it comes to DDOS
protection and the interesting wrinkle
technologically Downstream from this was
uh the actual Mirai botnet took
advantage of the internet of things
right it sort of spread itself to
devices other than computers and so
forth and that's a scary new thing we're
going to have to confront right yeah so
one of so one one argument that I make
in the book about out why up code we
should be thinking about up code rather
than down code is that up code shapes
down code gives people incentives to
produce code of certain certain type
another reason why upcoded is the thing
we should be focusing on rather than
down code and this story exemplifies
this reason is that the down code
uses data produced by the up code so
just think about it like this you know
so it doesn't matter how good your
operating system is it doesn't matter
how good your
cryptography is and none of that matters
is if you go to human resources and you
at or I.T of your of your company or a
different company and you ask them for
credentials to somebody else and they as
somebody else's account and they give it
to you so the the up code here would be
the corporate policies or the academic
policies about who who's entitled to
what data so it doesn't actually matter
how good your operating system is if
like the up code is just undermining it
so this is exactly what happens in the
Mirai botnet the mirai.net takes
advantages of what you said The Internet
of Things the internet of things like
smart toasters and camcorders and things
like that which are are devices which
are hooked up to the Internet and which
communicate with each other rather than
communicating primarily with human
beings and what
um when these internet of things came
online in 2014 2015 2016
um you know they can't they don't really
come with any security controls
um the you know the passwords are
default passwords like one two three or
password or admin or whatever because
who's gonna worry about the security of
their toaster
um and you know the these Mariah guys
they realize wait a second if there are
these all these default passwords
default passwords which they just found
through Google because they're in the
manuals so they download the PDFs in the
manuals they look at the passwords they
build they build a worm like not a worm
but a worm like botnet that exploits
these default passwords and and then are
able to create in just such an enormous
um uh digital cannon that I remember in
October 21st
2016 right before the election I
remember my internet goes out the for
the end for for most of the day and of
course everyone thinks it's Russia
um and it turns out to be these kids who
just exploit this very simple
um up code vulnerability you know using
default passwords and so they just
entered into
um these toasters
um and then
generate this enormous botnet which can
take down the internet
um and it's a again it's another example
of you know it doesn't matter how good
your Tech is if your policy surrounding
it are bad and this is the case where
they uploaded their code to the Internet
so anyone can do it my impression is
that this uh these sets of worms are
still going around
yes exactly I'm the Mirai there are many
many many different variants of the
Mirai bot and that's still around the
it's the one's called Satori I mean one
of the things also that you learn
um from doing this stuff is like you
know hackers lie
um I hate to break it to you but um so
what what they'll often do is they'll
often take the same malware and they'll
rename it with a different anime name
and then say it's the new
improved malware
um or somebody will take it and they
will package it as their own and they'll
Rebrand it
um as the matsusuko uh variant or
something like that but there's this is
this is still causing
um uh um significant problems around the
world
um uh through their
quite irresponsible action of
you know just releasing this very
powerful malware onto the internet
um you know the P you know boys young
men make terrible mistakes
um the these three these three boys
young men have they get they they plead
they are they're facing many years in
jail but
um the FBI and the FBI agent who catches
them uh a special agent Elliott Peterson
has this idea that what if we we can use
these
um
um uh skilled professionals
um for law enforcement and so
um instead of putting them in jail the
court orders them for 2500 hours of
community service where they are helping
the FBI catch a lot of these malware
prevailers so you have this kind of
Catch Me If You Can patch me if you can
type type situation so I I think this is
an A A really excellent model for how to
deal
um uh with some of these offenders
um and they're almost finished with
their community service um in October
they'll be finished and
um and they're it's a they're they're
Fascinating People well speaking of
young men and uh exploiting the up code
there's we can't get away without
talking about Paris Hilton's cell phone
yeah right yeah so I I you know
um so Paris Hilton
something's so upsetting is that like
some of my students don't know who Paris
Hilton is which really I mean doing this
doing this book really made me feel old
um so Paris Hilton of course it girl in
um big news that her cell phone was
hacked and nude photos were posted on
the internet and you can't get them down
and the big question is how the hell in
the world does this happen so Paris
Hilton
she comes on the scene around 2001 she's
like everywhere like every form of media
is Paris Hilton Paris Hilton Paris
Hilton and then we want to um and then
her phone her cell phone gets hacked and
people are like how can how could you
hack her phone she's constantly
surrounded by by bodyguards
um who's gonna like SN you know snatch
her phone and like do something
um people don't realize that in
2004-2005 we have this new invention
called the cloud yeah
um and that and not her cell phone is
not hacked it is the cloud that is
hacked and it is hacked by a 16 year old
boy
um known as Cameron Lacroix who um
figures out how to exploit web
interfaces in order to
um in order to gain access to data on
um on cell phones
um and he manages to get
Paris Hilton's
phone number he knows that she has a
T-Mobile account because he sees it
commercials which she's in with Snoop
Dogg
and then calls up a T-Mobile calls up a
T-Mobile office in California and says
that he's from corporate headquarters
and he wants the username and password
to their system to check if everything
is okay and the manager gives it to him
so he goes and he looks up Paris
Hilton's
um uh uh number he gets it and then he
realizes that if he wants to register
his
um uh a T-Mobile account all he has to
do is use a sidekick a sidekick at the
time had a deal with T-Mobile
uh that um that they would use
um that that would be the carrier
um and so
um if you try to register your phone
from the sidekick T-Mobile assumed that
you had it that you were T-Mobile
customer once you realized that he went
to his browser told his browser to
pretend to be the sidekicks browser and
then entered Paris Hilton's number and
got all her data I mean so it's it's
just you know it's a store and when you
why did he do it why did he do it yeah
of course he wanted to be famous so like
there's just like the upco you know so
you have Paris Hilton who's of course
famous for being famous you have this
you know 16 year old boy who you know
his mother dies when he's two years old
from a fentanyl overdose he has
depression he's suffering through
various types of
um um you know uh
um mental mental health concerns
um and he wants to be famous
um and he exploits these terrible
corporate policies of T-Mobile like give
your password over to somebody who
claims they're from corporate
um or let's build terrible terrible
authentication systems that don't work
um why are they doing it because they're
trying to gain as much market share as
they possibly can
um so you know you know the hackers out
there can be disappointed because it
turns out that the hack was so simple by
the way nobody knows a story now now
people will know the story I was able to
track Cameron Lacroix down after four
years because he was in jail in jail
during covid
um and it took me a very long time to
catch to to track him down it took me
about three years
um and then two weeks before the book
had to literally go to press I found out
the story the true story of how he acted
so oh okay well yeah yeah yeah well and
it's it's there there are themes
emerging here right I mean things are
there's an intrinsic worry with
computers because code and data are not
two separate things things become more
difficult to control when everything is
connected to everything else whether
it's a cloud where there's these devices
and the human beings are the weakest
link in in almost all these stories
yes absolutely I mean when it when it
all bottoms out it's like you know human
beings behind the keyboard
um yeah and um one of the things so you
know people might say what is a law
professor doing writing about cyber
security and I I want to say you know
one of the things that law professors do
is that we're coders we're up coders we
we think about and we help teach
students how to design and how to
implement up code
and I teach students how to hack because
I want them to understand the down code
the technology but really what I want
them to understand is how might we
change the rules to give people the
proper incentives either to produce
really good down code
or to ensure that they don't get fooled
by bad down code and so that's that
that's the that's the mission I think
it's a much more efficient cost
effective way of trying to solve these
problems and telling these stories
um are ways of getting people to see so
I explain all the technical stuff what a
buffer overflow is what how SQL
injections work yada yada but I also
want them to appreciate that there's
this other story going on actually the
two other stories there's a
philosophical story which we talked
about earlier and then there's the
social
um upcode story
um which is in many ways doing so much
of the work and it gets hidden because
people get
understandably freaked out by a
technical subject like cyber security
and they shut off and they think what
can I contribute actually
a tremendous amount because you
understand how human beings work
and I think it kind of all comes
together but in a slightly darker way in
the fancy bear story which gives your
book its title and I know that it was
the fourth of the five that you talk
about but to me it's the culmination of
the whole thing because it was malicious
from the start uh it was not a 16 year
old uh just messing around so I don't
know there's a lot of threads that come
into it where do you like to start
telling that story yeah so so um so it
so so many of the people in my book
um that initially I mean there's a
standard Trope which runs through so
much of cyber security history but
certainly this book there's a hack it's
spectacular
um uh some nation state probably Russia
did it and it kind of often turns out
that it's like teenagers
um okay but sometimes it turns out to be
russial
um and um one of the things I wanted to
show was like it's if you just look at
the technical indicators yes of course
attribution is always hard and um and
you can trick people and you know Bubble
at false flags and all that stuff
disinformational but you know it's
unbelievably hard to say that Russia did
not hack the DNC
um when you actually just kind of lay
out what we know from a publicly
available sources
um that's the first thing the second
thing so I really was so fascinated by
just like what the Bulgaria case why why
is all about why are all viruses coming
from Bulgaria I was like why did this
happen one of the central Mysteries of
the DNC case is the fact that the FBI it
took the FBI a year from learning that
Russia was in the DNC networks to
actually getting them to focus on it
meeting up with them to take care of it
and the question is why did the FBI take
so long to contact the Democratic
National many that Russians were in
their Network the second question is it
takes about six months for
um for the DNC to get back to the FBI
why don't they take it seriously so it
feels like everyone's messing up
everyone's acting irresponsibly but if
actually you understand the up code
you'll see that everyone's acting
perfectly rationally because there's
this one thing that is so Central to the
way the world works that most people
don't know which is that when hacking is
done for the purposes of collecting
National Security information it is
known as Espionage spying and spying is
legal under international law that is
why every state hacks every other state
so the fact that the FBI knows that the
Russia has hacked or is
gained a foothold in the Democratic
National Committee Network I think the
response is you know tell me something I
don't know
um you know the Russians had tried to
get into the White House the pentagonchi
joined Chiefs earlier
um they get thrown out and so what do
you do if you're an intelligence agency
you start looking
um wider you start looking for
um you know softer targets
the Russians aren't just in the DNC
they're in Brookings they're in you know
political science departments around the
country they're just looking everywhere
so like it's like dog bites man news at
11. it's like not news for people so
they don't take that seriously
um and then the DNC on the other hand
wasn't DNC respond well one of the
things you also have to understand about
the FBI is that it's a very unusual
institution because it's a hybrid one
half intelligence agency they catch spas
in the United States but another half
they're the main federal law enforcement
agency and so at the time that the the
DNC is being hacked Hillary Clinton is
being investigated for private email
server and so it's highly likely
um bordering uncertainty that the DNC is
worried that the FBI is contacting them
because they want information about
Hillary's emails here's another up code
piece that most people don't know
um FBI prosecutors may not lie FBI
agents are they are allowed to lie the
person who contacted the DNC was from
the law enforcement side and it was an
agent he wasn't lying but he was allowed
to lie so on the one hand you have the
uh the FBI you know basically calling
around to everyone saying you know you
probably have Russians in your system
the DNC is like you're not gonna fool me
um and so everyone's kind of acting
rationally given given the circumstance
of the way intelligence and the FBI
works and the cultural social political
setting at the time and it it all comes
together because there's one other
change in up code that nobody predicts
that is the basic principle is that of
course other states are allowed to
um uh invade the digital systems of
another to collect at least National
Security information
but you're supposed to keep it quiet
you're not supposed to dump it and a
Cozy Bear
um which is in the the network for a
year they just keep the information
because they're trying to you know
produce analysis for
for the Kremlin whereas fancy bear takes
this information and does something
which had not been done before which is
this massive dump of information which
takes something from Espionage and turns
it more into something that some people
have been tempted to say is cyber War so
everyone's following the up code at the
time and the big disaster happens
because there's a change
um and I think when you think about it
that way things become much more
explicable it seems to make sense it's
not a mystery and then we should start
thinking how do we deal with these
situations and I always like to imagine
that you know someone 50 years from now
is listening to these podcasts so just
to be perfectly clear uh this was a hack
that we're pretty sure is done by the
Russian government of the Democratic
National Committee uh the political
party and they released a lot of emails
right before a presidential election and
it might have had a kind of big impact
on that presidential election yes I'm
sorry you're absolutely right I was
assuming that everyone knows about the
DNC hacks
um of uh by Russia in 2016 but you know
now we think about this is seven years
ago I know
um it's so real to me yeah um it's so
live but you're right that's exactly
what happened and I should have
explained that and you do a pretty good
job to the extent that it's even
possible which is very hard of like
painting the reality of this Russian
agency like we know a little bit about
it right
yeah actually we know a lot about it
because as it turns out
um you know I I was speaking to somebody
very high up in the CIA who once told me
the biggest problem that the CIA faces
that no one can be a spy anymore
um why because unless you are raised in
a hermetically sealed box
um the you know you have you know you
have social media accounts you have tons
of things that you
um that we say on the internet
especially like if you're 13 14 15 16
years old and then maybe you get
recruited by the Russian government
at some point and you go into the
intelligence agency
um and uh then you have all these people
uh like bellingcat and these uh uh open
source intelligence firms going around
looking at Russian Facebook and trying
to see do these people have a um a
Facebook account and yes they do and you
know the amazing things that you can
find like fan
when they when they when they registered
their cars they used Fancy Bear's
address
um they they don't have very good
operational security as it turns out but
one of the I mean I think the big lesson
here
is that in a world where everyone is
connected in a world of social media
um it's unbelievably difficult to be
anonymous
um and so now if you if you look up you
can learn a lot about
um the various Bears
um I talk about some of these people in
the book
um but you can learn a lot about them if
you Google because there are researchers
out there that are mining the internet
for all this and yet despite the in
according with the themes that we've
been talking about despite the massive
resources of this state-sponsored agency
uh technologically and so forth The
crucial step as I understand it was John
podesta giving up his password to the
Russians yeah that you know this this
makes me cringe so
so bad because
um so the so I mean it's
let me Begin by saying that
securing a political campaign is
incredibly difficult it's incredibly
difficult because lots of times people
come in from outside as to be part of
the campaign and they have a zillion
social media accounts they have they
have different phones they have
different you know and so there are just
so many ways to kind of
get into
um a political campaign so let me just
begin
um by by saying that it's a very very uh
difficult problem to to secure a
political campaign so the I.T person
they don't actually have a dedicated I.T
person it's a consultant
um and
um uh he um
I'm sorry I'm gonna back up because
um
um okay John podesta
um when one of the ironies of but her
emails uh the Hillary Clinton uh email
Scandal is that sure campaigning had
excellent cyber security they used
two-factor authentication
um Robbie Mook the campaign manager had
signs on the bathroom mirror saying you
don't share your toothbrush don't share
your password the Russians initially
were not able to get into Hillary for
America so what did they do they started
looking around
and they started going after the
personal accounts in this case the Gmail
accounts of people high up in the uh
campaign and they targeted John podesta
John podesta got a phishing email which
had said that Google it was ostensibly
from Google it was not it was from fancy
bear it was sent out
um you know during Russian uh during
Moscow working hours
um and it said that um uh somebody has
it as somebody has your
um password you should change it and
John podesta sends his email to
um to it saying hey is this legitimate
and the guy writes back this is a
legitimate email
and he claims he meant to say this is
not a legitimate email I love that story
and it's even plausible it makes you
just wanna die
um now I would just say I you know it
sounds like a lie but I believe it and
the reason why I believe it is because
like I.T had been seeing these phishing
emails come across their their their the
network for several weeks before they
caught
um um podesta so it's highly unlikely
that
oh I should say
you know from the outside it seems
unlikely that
um that they were fooled
um I think he meant to say this is not a
legitimate email
um and he just you know sometimes we
mistype and
oh my Lord
um you know he changes his password
um which is handing his password to the
credentials to Russian military
intelligence they immediately go in
change the password get all of his files
and it becomes a scandal when they
release podesta's shrimp risotto
um recipe it just shows how
um
it was the appearance of something the
the doxing
um well it wasn't exactly doxing the
exfiltration and dumping of the
information there wasn't that much in
the information that was so
um uh important
um or politically damaging there were
some things that were but it was more
the appearance of people dumping all
this information and saying oh my God
look at this this is a corrupt
organization and people like oh yeah I
guess you're right
um and so that just
um you know again
um a serious uh human vulnerability
which uh led to
um very uh damaging political
consequences and presumably it's not the
last that we're seeing of this I I know
that it's hard to predict the future but
I mean maybe say for our final wrap-up
thought here a little bit about how you
tried to write a book that
uh straddle the line between uh crazy
alarmist and oh don't worry we'll here's
how to fix it yeah no that's right so
like so I think cyber security books
have this on the one hand
we're all gonna die
um part to it I mean and then we're
seeing this with AI we're all going to
die and then the other side is like eat
your vegetables make sure your password
is 20 characters long you know it's just
like this just bummer
um and so what I try to do is I try to
kind of steer between alarmism and
complacency so here's here's a kind of
bottom line I would say to people
most people you know hackers don't care
about you
they don't even care about your data so
much
um by by which I mean like your you know
the pictures of your kids or the kind of
um you know Arch thing you said about
your friend
um oh over over email what they want is
to make money and
um and it's a high volume uh business
you know they're scanning the internet
they're sending out these phishing
emails
um and basically they do not want to get
into your computer because they want to
spy on you let's see you make dinner
what they want is to either you know
pull your your your laptop into a botnet
or they want to use it they want to
exfiltrate your banking information
credit card information maybe they want
to encrypt your hard drive
um
they don't want to spend that much time
on you and so they want to catch the
people who are kind of Reckless who
don't really take any precautions who
essentially leave the keys in their car
with the door unlocked running
um don't click on links from people you
don't know you know don't don't wait
20 months before you update your
computer it doesn't mean you got to do
it you know this second just don't be
Reckless if you are not Reckless for
most of us we will be fine because we
just have to be faster than the next guy
we just have to make sure that we are
not an easy target that is not true for
so-called high-value targets
high value targets which I'm including
journalism politicians people in the
c-suite you know cocfo CEOs
um you know human rights activists
people like that government government
officials they are high value targets
they might you they must assume that
they are being targeted they should have
professional help
um unless they're sophisticated
um and
I I'm not being an alarmist to say if
you're a human rights activist or a
journalist or C CEO you really need to
be really battened down because people
will try to get you another thing I want
to say is that there's no way we will
ever stop the hacking of nation states
against nation states for the purposes
of getting National Security information
because that's what states do their job
is to protect their
their state maybe their power and it is
legal it's probably beneficial for
states to
know secrets of other states
so um you know the the person who reads
this book who's not a high value Target
I think it's you know some very basic
things that you can do not to get
yourself hard in In Harm's Way but if
you are a high value Target I will
describe the various ways in which you
could get caught and you really ought to
um
um seek expert help well I think that
almost by definition every listener of
the mindscape podcast is a high value
Target so I think that they should all
buy your book and uh that will be very
helpful to them yeah no that's that's
absolutely right I mean it's it's
Reckless not to buy my book it's
Reckless we wouldn't want that so Scott
Shapiro thanks so much for viewing the
mindscape podcast oh thank you so much
this was really fun I really appreciate
it thank you
[Music]
thank you